let's do a worked example where we
calculate the standard change in free
energy delta g naught for a chemical
reaction and for our reaction let's look
at the synthesis of ammonia gas from
nitrogen gas and hydrogen gas
at 25 degrees celsius delta h naught for
this reaction is equal to negative 92.2
kilojoules per mole of reaction since
delta h naught is negative this reaction
is exothermic and at 25 degrees celsius
delta s naught for this reaction is
equal to negative
198.7 joules per kelvin mole of reaction
our goal is to calculate delta g naught
for this reaction at 25 degrees celsius
remember if delta g naught is negative
the forward reaction is
thermodynamically favorable but if delta
g naught is positive the forward
reaction is thermodynamically
unfavorable
since the change in enthalpy is negative
and the change in entropy is negative
whether or not delta g naught is
negative depends on the temperature
to calculate the value for delta g
naught we're going to use the following
equation delta g naught is equal to
delta h naught minus t delta s naught
where t is the temperature in kelvin
next we need to plug everything into our
equation so delta h naught is equal to
negative 92.2 kilojoules per mole of
reaction the temperature is 25 degrees
celsius so 25 plus 273
is equal to 298 kelvin so we're going to
plug 298 kelvin into our equation
and for delta s naught notice we have
this in joules whereas for delta h
naught it was in kilojoules so we need
to convert delta s naught into
kilojoules per kelvin mole of reaction
one way to do that is just to move the
decimal place three to the left which
gives us negative 0.1987
kilojoules per kelvin mole of reaction
so we're going to plug all of this in
for delta s naught
here's our equation with everything
plugged in notice that kelvin will
cancel out which gives us kilojoules per
mole of reaction as our units and when
we do the math we find that delta g
naught is equal to negative 33.0
kilojoules per mole of reaction
because delta g naught is negative that
means the reaction is thermodynamically
favorable in the forward direction and
the superscript knot means that both the
reactants and products are in their
standard states so what our calculation
tells us is if we had a mixture of
nitrogen hydrogen and ammonia gas at 25
degrees celsius and all three gases had
a partial pressure of one atmosphere
the reaction is thermodynamically
favorable in the forward direction
meaning nitrogen gas and hydrogen gas
would come together to synthesize or
make more ammonia
so at 298 kelvin delta g naught for this
reaction is negative let's do another
calculation for this same reaction at a
different temperature a temperature of 1
000 kelvin also even though the value
for delta g naught is highly dependent
on temperature the values for delta h
naught and delta s naught are not as
dependent on the temperature
therefore we're going to assume that
these values for delta h naught and
delta s naught don't change and we're
going to use the same ones at the higher
temperature of 1000 kelvin
here's the equation with everything
plugged in for the calculation of delta
g naught at the higher temperature of
1000 kelvin and notice that the values
we're using for delta h naught and delta
s naught are the same as the ones that
we used at the lower temperature of 298
kelvin once again kelvin cancels out and
gives us kilojoules per mole of reaction
as our units for our final answer
and after we do the math we find that
delta g naught is equal to positive
106.5 kilojoules per mole of reaction
since delta g naught is positive that
means the forward reaction is
thermodynamically unfavorable which
means the reverse reaction is
thermodynamically favorable so if we had
a mixture of nitrogen gas hydrogen gas
and ammonia gas at a temperature of 1000
kelvin and all three gases had a partial
pressure of one atmosphere the ammonia
gas would turn into nitrogen gas and
hydrogen gas and while we have both
calculations on the screen let's analyze
why one calculation gives a negative
value for delta g naught and the other
one gives a positive value for the
calculation at 298 kelvin the
temperature was low enough that the
entropy term
didn't overwhelm the negative value for
the enthalpy term and we ended up with a
negative overall value for delta g
naught
however for the calculation at 1000
kelvin this time the temperature was
high enough where the entropy term
outweighed the negative value for the
enthalpy term and therefore the overall
value for delta g naught ended up being
positive
we've just seen that for the synthesis
of ammonia from nitrogen gas and
hydrogen gas at relatively low
temperatures like 298 kelvin delta g
naught is less than zero and at
relatively high temperatures like 1000
kelvin delta g naught is greater than
zero
so there must be some temperature
between 298 kelvin and 1000 kelvin where
the forward reaction goes from being
thermodynamically favorable to
thermodynamically unfavorable and this
crossover point occurs when the enthalpy
term and the entropy term are perfectly
balanced therefore delta g naught is
equal to zero at this crossover point
so we plug in zero for delta g naught
and we solve for the temperature at the
crossover point after some algebra we
find that the temperature is equal to
delta h naught divided by delta s naught
which is equal to negative 92.2
kilojoules per mole of reaction divided
by negative 0.1987
kilojoules per kelvin mole of reaction
kilojoules per mole of reaction cancels
out and gives us
464 kelvin for the crossover temperature
so for this particular reaction delta g
naught is equal to zero at 464 kelvin at
temperatures less than 464 kelvin the
forward reaction is thermodynamically
favorable however at temperatures higher
than 464 kelvin the forward reaction is
thermodynamically unfavorable